Republican Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
is trying to revoke the Orlando
philharmonic's liquor license because
they hosted a Christmas-themed drag show
this is the latest anti-woke mind virus
they have become obsessed with drag
queens when in reality they should be
looking elsewhere and they should be
looking inward this is virtue signaling
of the highest order the Wright loves to
say the left virtue signals but it is
actually they on the right that do the
virtue signaling this is completely
meaningless this is not a big deal there
is no danger to children from drag
queens drag performers drag shows drag
time story hour but they don't care it
plays well with their masses and so
they're going they're going to keep at
it